welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the book
of boba fett episode 7 the finale in the
name of honor as this mixed bag of a
season with very high highs comes to a
close i'm gonna explain all the subtle
details that you might have missed in
this finale episode some really great
star wars easter eggs just some awesome
cinematic details that are easy to
overlook and really what the actual book
of the book of boba fett really was
because i'll tell you there's actually
several things about that book that you
might not know just by looking at it
also you can join us as we chat about
this stuff live in chicago a live event
we're doing tomorrow 8pm italia hall if
you live in the chicago area you got to
come check this out we're doing this
with rooster teeth's very normal podcast
tour ticket link in the description also
by the way you can get your hands on
this great boba fett inspired shirt at
newrockstarsmerch.com where when you get
one you can write in a custom shout out
for our star wars after shows so this
episode opens in the city of mos espa
long shadow cast over it after the
tragic bombing of gossip whip sanctuary
odd vfx detail i caught that tall tower
at the heart of the town now sits beside
this large dome structure whereas the
establishing shot back in episode 1
placed that building a few blocks away
but in the bottom right corner you can
see those red canopies hanging in the
street that's actually the street that
leads to garcia's club where down in the
street level shots you can see those
same red canopies leading up to it
inside boba says even if we win
there might not be anything left of the
city that really is boba's ultimate
concern like that chicago diner bombing
from brian de palma's the untouchables
that inspired this attack last episode
is it really worth engaging in this kind
of urban warfare if it destroys the city
or trying to save this season we saw a
similar fate befall mandalore the empire
bombed it so no one could have it it's
also been suggested this to be the
backstory of tatooine which used to be a
lush landscape and after boba learned
how the tuscans inherited this
inhospitable terrain it's now his
priority to preserve any scrapple
civilization this planet has left mando
says they have the support of freetown
if they end the spice trade which
finnick objects to saying keeping the
hud spice lines would maintain the
status quo and give them some money
there's a lot of credits to be made from
that orange powder now spice is mined
and manufactured on kessel we saw that
in solo star wars story but now we're
seeing how it's shipped and distributed
on tatooine where gangsters like jabba
the hutt and the pikes sell it to
dealers all in this one hub and as we've
seen this season those shipments result
in these violent train lines that kill
banthas and tuscans sails that interrupt
moisture harvesting all preventing
tatooine from truly prospering and
growing spice is killing our people
so therefore true change requires spice
to just be banned from this planet or
maybe just take cobb vance hamster name
approach and legalize it tax it raise
some public revenue to build some gaffy
tree parks you know cad bane strips up
through maz eisley passing these two
jawas stripping parts off a speeder
these actually are probably the same two
jawas who lifted pike tech for
pelimoto's shop and he meets with the
pike leader and mayor mokshais i have to
respond i have to respond in some way
now the mayor is voiced by director
robert rodriguez himself who also voices
the trained ocean leader at the end of
the episode and as an ithorian he speaks
through these orifices on the side of
his head translated through a
transmitter at the top of his head i
just love it in star wars where all the
characters in the scene are all
non-human faces now the pike leader
voiced by phil lamar confirms that it
was the pikes not the nekto speeder gang
who killed the tuscans we left evidence
behind to encourage such a conclusion
they were charging us protection
we have to protect our margins so as we
suspected it was the pikes who painted
that nikto gang symbol on the tuscan
tents meaning that boba by violently
killing those nectos for the pikes has
really been playing the pike's game this
whole time the whole time cat bane is
surprised i didn't realize the pike
syndicate was so ruthless cadbane later
even tells bobo what the pikes did
taking that advantage away from them and
really stripping this game down to just
a personal matter between the
gunslingers which is really how cad
prefers to do business yet his refusal
to play this game and his insistence on
facing boba even when the pikes were
routed really results on cad not making
it out of this episode on his two feet
you gotta play the game cad says that
all depends on how much your two
stomachs can bear yes aythorians have
their two mouths which lead to two
stomachs they also have four throats
r2d2 pilots luke's x-wing to maz eisley
where pelimoto's pit droids awaken two
first who kick the other awake on the
screen the oribes translates to x-wing
bd1 watches in anticipation as the gank
droid passes along with the r5 astromech
droid and the treadwell droid and pele
tells them hide that get rid of that
hello officer
hi
officer i filed for my new republic
certification seal tucked as you were
landing yeah she tells her droids to
cover all those stolen goods and notice
how that petroids tarp just slips right
off the crate anyway and then the pit
droid just kind of leans against that
crate all casual like nothing to see
here now pele assumes this is one of the
other new republic officers that we've
seen in next wings before but this
x-wing does not have the markings that
we saw on captain carson tv's x-wing
back in mandalorian season 2 but rather
this is luke's x-wing from the original
trilogy later appearing in the last jedi
in the rise of skywalker and of course
in the mandalorian season 2 finale yet
luke is not piloting this he left r2 and
groku to travel alone perhaps thinking
that it's best for grogu to just cut off
his jedi ties immediately did they teach
you how to fly an x-wing already
i know when astromech blew the ship
like r5 did in episode 5 her droids
always correct her when she suggests
they might be extraneous and unnecessary
now r2 did pilot ships by himself in the
past like he flew mace windu starfighter
and clone wars alone and other astromech
droids have done this in revenge of the
sith obi-wan had r7 pilot his
starfighter back to the republic ship so
that he could trick general grievous and
think he left ooda pop just so he could
get the best effort drop on them hello
there pelly greets grogu let me say
hello to my old pal
hello bright eyes yeah it looks like
rogue who vocalized a little response
there the kid's starting to talk folks
and she calls him bright eyes the
nickname for charlton heston's character
and planet of the apes yet pele hates
his real name rogo whoa that's a
terrible name sorry about that pal the
way am i calling you that yes giving
voice to all the people who still call
him baby yoda belly feeds him some dung
worms stinky worms that are sold as food
on tatooine first seen in the phantom
menace video game and when grogu eats
one he does a little head bobble
he's loving it back in most espa the
mods ride past the gammoreans at the
platoonian controlled spaceport and then
pass or santan in the transition
controlled city center you'll notice two
transitions passed right by him with a
container showing how these transitions
are actually secretly setting up their
surprise attacks similarly a few
aqualish clocked the mods as they pass
in the workers district another craning
his head around the door as they park
all of these gotchas waiting for their
moment and despite these airtight
defenses the slow moving cat bane just
walks right up a red flag that their
defenses actually ain't worse like
he's not even sneaking he's standing in
the middle of the street i love how he
always struts like a western gunslinger
he was actually initially inspired by
lee van cleef's angel eyes and the good
bad the ugly cat says if that's not the
quack to call in the stiffling slimy
which is a callback to boba fett saying
this to costco reeves in the mandalorian
i didn't know sidekicks were allowed to
talk
all of that isn't the quakta calling the
stiffling slimy telling this there was a
shared past history between cat and boba
where they had this kind of shorthand
probably came from django too in dave
filoni's unfinished clone wars season
six arc boba and cad actually dueled
resulting in that famous dent in boba's
helmet throughout this episode they do
hint at knowing each other when they
were both younger don't toy with me
i'm not a little boy any longer
and you are an old man when cad reveals
he beat cobb vance the camera pushes in
on boba followed by this new angle on
cad that bathed simon blind in sunlight
and dust just showing boba's sudden
disorientation and viewing cad now is a
more serious threat the aqualicious
trans oceans of the clotunians
completely unsurprisingly betray team
boba these plutonians initially appear
on the other side of these passing train
cars just like that shot and once upon a
time in the west and these poor
gomorians don't make it
finnick saves the mods thank you
manners
i like it
you're welcome remember finnick also got
mod enhancements from that same mod
artist making her technically part of
the same class as the rest of them the
pikes arrive led by this unmasked pike
soldier one of the rare times in live
action a pike has presented himself in
public without a mask showing how this
badass is not afraid of these
atmospheric conditions mando refuses to
abandon boba it's against the creed
and you really buy into that bentham
photo
i do
so despite the armorer shunning mando he
is still a true believer in the creed of
no mando left behind as paz vizsla put
his life at risk to save him on navarro
he quotes the episode's title we'll both
die in the name of honor you sure you
want to stay
this is the way and since mando at this
point believes grogo has chosen life
with the jedi he has no reason to
preserve his own life in the name of
anything else the major domo butts in i
was educated on coruscant not that that
makes me better in any way get to it i
attended finishing academy my parents
were not wealthy by any means
i specialized in civic council
negotiations so it sounds like this
major domo essentially got a degree in
the same kind of robert's rules of order
that senator turn chancellor palpatine
used to corrupt and destroy the senate
on coruscant so not helpful here but he
tells the pikes someday i hope to see
the fabled obsidian cliffs of obadiah
with my own eyes yes obadiah is the pike
home world and obsidian is a rare stone
in the star wars universe used by vader
to build his fortress on mustafar and
obsidian can actually be found in some
red kyber crystals infused with the dark
side of the force now the major tomos
tablet that bobo wrote all this down on
is actually a 1970s colico bulatronic
game i love it when they make props out
of toys like that and from this he reads
boba's offer hi
boba fett
speaking as daimyo of the tatooine
territories formerly held by job in the
hut do present the following offer
nothing
yes a very generous offer evoking
michael corleone's offer in the
godfather part two my offer is this
nothing now this handwritten note by
boba is i believe the book of boba fett
of this show's title because not only is
it the one thing written by boba fett
anywhere in the series it actually
includes some poetry and allusions to
myth if you refuse these terms
the arid sands of tatooine will once
again flourish with flowered fields
fertilized with the bodies of your dead
yes flourish with floured fields
fertilized that's poetic alliteration
folks a citing the fabled history told
to him by the tuscans about tatooine as
a planet once being lush covered in
water and vegetation and the major domo
tags it with his words yeah a joke
probably because you don't work and
you're lazy
but also feels like the way bible
readings at church services end with the
word of the lord because this is boba
preaching his vision for this planet
free from the pain of spice restored to
the life-bearing gaffy trees and ripe
fruits that they actually enjoy in the
final scene but really could argue this
is just written to be super wordy so
that both of them can surprise us all on
their jet packs bobo once again uses his
knee missile that he used on tython in
the mandalorian last season
he actually pulls the same move later
lifting his knee and firing his blaster
at the same time striking my favorite
pose ever amanda releases his old
whistling birds but they realize they
are outgunned they both actually have to
repeatedly blast one sniper behind them
definitely a redundant effort that
leaves them exposed also the slow motion
shot of shooting the guy as he falls in
the air definitely seems like robert
rodriguez making a nod to his own shot
in desperado now boba fett has clearly
been building his squad all season long
sparing no expense and if you want to
build your own squad of star wars
collectibles our friends at whatnot are
here to help whatnot is a live video
shopping app think uh star wars hologram
communication meets online auction yes
right on your phone a collectibles
expert will be live on screen chatting
with the community and selling cool
collectibles find the best funko pops
action figurines comics maybe even a
lightsaber or two on the whatnot app yes
i've been using it to go crazy on
mandalorian and star wars themed funkos
i even got this one with mando with
grogu on a bantha i really just got it
for the bantha i love these things
whatnot brings together a community of
fans built around the things you love
hop into a star wars auction and chat
with other fans meet knowledgeable
collectors maybe even discover an
unexpected gym oh no
oh no and you know what it's not just
star wars memorabilia there are auctions
for comics sports cards action figures
and all the cool stuff you'd like to
have lining your walls most of these
auctions start at just one dollar so you
can be sure to find a deal there's even
an occasional celebrity guest cameo and
fun giveaways so download whatnot today
using the link in this video's
description to get ten dollars off your
first purchase and just like i found
ahsoka here maybe you'll even find a
funko pop of denjarin but thankfully the
freetown weekway bartender played by w
earl brown timothy olafan's co-star from
deadwood we now learn his name is tanti
he pilots a v35 speeder as backup this
model was actually created for the 1997
special edition of a new hope but the
pisces unleash scorpenac droids these
scorpion-inspired droids were originally
concept are designed for attack of the
clones but they have since been adopted
as part of star wars history dating back
to the clone wars they are meant to be
larger versions of the droid codes
within the menace thus their same
particle energy shields this is their
first live-action appearance and i love
how here you can see how the lucasfilm
team designed their appendages to be
curved and segmented like the barbed
tail of a scorpion boba uses his
targeting system
yeah that sound effect was the same
sound effect used during the trench run
in a new hope
after amando's darksaber fails to
penetrate those shields he says our
energy weapons can't get through and our
kinetic weapons have too much velocity
now later we can see how larger
creatures like black crystal and the
rancor are just able to break through
barely by applying greater force more
slowly like you can see how bk's
knuckles just begin to break through
this slow shield penetration reminds us
of the holtzman shield generators of
dune one of many things star wars ripped
off from dune those shield generators
also require slow moving blades to
penetrate blasters don't work or they do
but like boom to penetrate these shields
if only they had saw guerrera here to
teach them to roll grenades under the
shields like he taught us to do in clone
wars before scad's super necessary twirl
you can actually hear pyke yell at them
yes sleemo the hutty's profanity
translating to slimeball just granny doe
pot slamo peli and her petroids arrive
in a rickshaw pulled by an ric droid
anakin and padme actually rode one of
these and attack the clones as that
scorbeneck rounds the corner one pitcher
just grabs his knees and trembles i bet
that's the sleepy one from earlier drash
tells the free towners i grew up put one
pot from him yes referring to womp rats
which luke skywalker also uses a
measuring stick womp wrapper scale but
it's not impossible i used to bullseye
womp rats in my t-16 back home they're
not much bigger than two meters grogu
having chosen the best guard chain mail
reunites with mando hey what are you
doing here
oh okay little guy
i'm happy to see you too yes he forced
leaps into bando's arms showing how he
did learn some skills from master luke
except now his application the force is
in service of love this is his way crew
who even reaches out his little hand to
the edge of mando's helmet as of trying
to crest his face maybe even to lift his
helmet off just like he did the last
moment they saw each other pelly says
the force works in mysterious ways
another example of how the force is
often considered a divine concept god
works in mysterious ways similar
descriptions have been used by yoda in
comics and in the legends novel darth
plagueis by james lucerno the rickshaw
crashes mano has a jet pack to catch
grogu the pit droids just clamp up to
reduce the impact but poor pelley lands
face first spitting out a tooth boba's
rancor arrives i love his gradual
appearance just peeking out over those
rooftops at first evoking the way
godzilla is often showed fins first of
the buildings in the touhou films the
rancor lowers its head revealing bobo
riding it in a saddle with stirrups
recalling boba fett's first ever
appearance in star wars holiday special
grogu uses a force to yank out of the
scorpion egg a ball joint this little
kid always just wants the ball shaped
parts for toys but i love how it doesn't
hurt him because he is wearing that
chain mail you can actually hear the
clink when it hits him
the rancor is able to overwhelm that
first scorpioneck and boba orders
do it
yes killing the opponent by uncrossing
the arms severing it kind of like how
anakin did to dooku when he was given
the same order gilly
and then on to the second scorpion neck
the rancor grabs his blasters coming
face to face with its red photoreceptor
eye giving that rancor a target to focus
on and then so after using the severed
limb to block that blast it digs its
thumb into its eye during all this pelle
meets the major domo i am not a threat
nice head tails come on get behind me
pretty face kelly's got you covered yes
amy sedaris and dave pasquazzi both
performed at chicago's second city
theater around when john favreau trained
in the city's comedy scene these two
have co-starred on strangers with candy
and on sedaris's crazy true tv show what
kind of knife are you using tony the
kind with the serial numbers filed off i
like to call her daddy's girl little
detail i love here a pike tries to hide
behind a column from the rancor but that
rancor just smashes through the column
to grab him leading to this
i love that teamwork you killed this one
daddy and then yeah you probably heard a
wilhelm scream edited in there cad bane
spooks a rancor with his flamethrower
and then he asks boba one thing i can't
figure what's your angle this is my city
these are my people i will not abandon
them yeah cat is asking the question we
all have like why does boba feel such a
loyalty to this city filled with water
brokers who hate his guts i think his
gaffy tree quest left him with a deep
connection to the sansa tatooine which
is now his new homeland in which he
links the dune sea with the crashing
waves of kamino bobo was re-birthed from
the sarlacc he was rebirthed from the
tree roots and now he feels bound to
protect this land but despite his age
cad is 71 here he wins the quick draw on
boba twice but you've got your father's
blood pumping through your veins this
isn't the first time i beat you out on a
job i would love to see their full
backstory at some point hopefully cat
survived or maybe we might see it
earlier in the timeline like they were
both around during the timeline of
obi-wan kenobi that series coming may
25th as well as the andor series
hopefully coming later this year cad
pulls his helmet off and he says
consider this my final lesson look out
for yourself anything else
is weakness but he does have a favor
here because now with his helmet off
bobo remembers his time before regaining
his armor and he closes his eyes
meditating like in his flashback does
recalling his past with the tuscans the
first time he learned that actually
tribe is more important than the
individual and so he uses his tuscan
gaffy stick to defeat cad both
physically and in ideology he stabs cat
yeah you'll notice cad's voice there
actually a product of his chest
modulator from his past wounds and the
fact that air is directed into his lungs
through the back where it would bypass
his trachea and his vocal cords also i
love this as his hat comes off he has a
plate on his head this from the same
duel that dented boba's helmet a moment
that we thought cad died in but now it
looks like both gunslingers did
successfully score some headshots as
boba walks off cat is left in the sand
with a red dial blinking on his chest
he seems out for the count but i don't
know i think that light indicates his
survival meanwhile the rancor rampages
hurling a speeder at them concept art
actually shows a moment the rancor was
gonna grab that speeder and shake out
the passengers the ranker climbs the
tower just like king kong mando gives
grogu his old shifter knob that grogu
had twisted off as a toy that was the
one piece that mando recovered from the
razer crest wreckage after it was
destroyed and mando bravely engages the
rancor the rancor is pissed and roars
giving us this great moment
i love how they're both freaking out but
look over at grogu he doesn't even
flinch he just judges and so grogu
unafraid recalls his defeat of the
mudhorn in the first season but now
takes an even more empathetic path by
using the force to connect with the
inner soul of the raging beast as danny
trejo told us rancors are actually quite
sensitive it's so sweet to see grogo
using a less violent means to subdue it
showing how he's really grown beyond his
chaotic force choking past now as a
family foundling seeking to understand
and so grogu now spent just as he was
after beating the mudhorn takes a little
nap nuzzling up against the rancor
because he too is a sensitive soul
haunted by his past just trying to set
his mind at ease pal equips i'm guessing
there's not going to be a barbecue
calling back the random roasted meat
she's always cooking as we saw in the
mandalorian last season now back in moz
iceland with those stormtrooper helmets
on pikes spinnick actually makes a new
gruesome display out of their successors
slaying each of those gotcha heads and
violently hanging mock shades even with
this curved ithorian head thenx lasso
seals both mouth orifices cutting off
his air after the battle the moss espa
spaceport now shows some happier
travelers arriving to this planet
tourism booming a contrast from those
trouble bringing pikes that we saw
arriving here before as boba and fenik
tore the recovering streets his theme
music returns
[Music]
yeah it sounds like composer joseph
shirley now plays it with a pan flute
almost like this is all just a super
friendly wren fair some kids offer him a
maileroon fruit the fruit from rebels
that the major domo crashed into a card
of boba tosses it to black kursantin who
joins them with the mods and that
depressed lep series ratcatcher droid
great visual detail here as the camera
rises over the town we cross dissolve
into the curvature of tatooine in space
but leaving us with a few frames of
superimposition making it look like a
rainbow of peace stretching over the
town because as this book of boba fett
draws to a close we get a biblical
illusion of god's covenant with noah
after the flood grogu rides in the
enclosed astromech port of the n1
starfighter tapping that shifter knob to
beg mando to hit that sublight thruster
i love how his breath fogs the canopy
just a little detail they added either
practically from under the puppet or
more likely with vfx just to make grogu
look more like a bored kid on a road
trip breathing against the car window
and framing grogu in that jump seat
directly over mando's head is just a
perfect way to leave these two grogu
positioned at the top of mando's mind
like a guardian angel protecting him but
also the best ideal light bulb this
gunslinger has ever had you probably
caught how this episode the credits play
the boba fett theme music
and yeah the vocalists are now singing
the theme with the words boba and fat
bow
what a goofy acapella group they are now
the post credit scene reveals the new
occupant of bubba's back to tank
god banff wearing a turtleneck i mean
none of us assumed this guy was dead
since we all saw him get shot in the
shoulder but also returning his bass
guitarist thundercat as that mod artist
heat rising from his instruments to give
cobb the old fennec treatment but i
think the most important detail is what
is not in the shot because throughout
this series we've always come back to
see boba in this tank with his boba fett
armor rested off to the side but now the
armor is not here and neither is boba
cobb was the only other person we've
seen in these series to wear boba's
armor but he gave it up a detail that
had bane repeatedly pointed out and now
that armor is back where it belongs and
boba no longer needs this bath because
now finally his inner scars have healed
i want to thank you all so much for
joining me for these breakdowns i mean
these seven episodes had some real high
highs just was always a delight to dive
deep into them each week with you guys
now i'm gonna be doing this a lot more
when obi-wan kenobi comes to disney plus
may 25th follow me on instagram and
twitter at avos follow new rockstar
subscribe to rockstars for more analysis
of everything you love thanks for
watching
[Music]
you